اختار رئيس كوريا الشماليه كيم جونغ ايون
هي سنه 2022 بثلاث تجارب صاروخيه وان يبدا
السنه الجديده بتجربه سارقيه اخرى
يحاولوا
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها في المنطقه
خصوصا كوريا الجنوبيه تحت الضغط وكان ذلك
واضحا في خطابه نهايه السنه الذي دعا فيه
الى الزياده من انتاج الصواريخ البالسيه
وتاكد الارقام هذا السعيد اذا اطلقتك اكثر
من 70 صاروخا خلال 2022
امام هذا الوضع زادت كوريا الجنوبيه من
استعداداتها العسكريه واجرى التجارب
صاروخيه لاختبار قدرتها على الرد على اي
هجوم من جارتها الشماليه وقال الرئيس
الكوري الجنوبي ان بلاده والولايات
المتحده تناقشان اجراء مناورات باشراك
القدرات النوويه الامريكيه لمواجهه
التهديد النووي لكوريا الشماليه واوضح ان
المظله النوويه الامريكيه لم تعد كافيه
لطمئنه بلاده
هدد رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه بان النظام
سينتهي اذا استخدم السلاح النووي وهو
تهديد لوحت به واشنطن من قبل يعرفوا كيمو
مخاطر استخدام السلاح النووي لكنه يعرف
ايضا منافع الضغط على خصومه لتحقيق مكاسب
داخليه وابعاد اي خطر خارجي
لابقاء لمنطقه في حاله توتر من اجل ذلك
لكنه ليس مصدر التوتر الوحيد في المنطقه
فالخلافات بشان تايوان زادت وتيتها ودفعت
الصين ايضا الى ممارسه الضغوط القصوى على
خصومها قالت اليابان انها ارسلت طائرات
وسفنا حربيه خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
لمراقبه حامله طائرات وسبع سفن حربيه
صينيه كانت تجري مناورات في المحيط
الهادئه واوضحت ان القطع الحربيه الصينيه
مرت بين جزيرتين نياكمه
للعبور من بحر جنوب الصين الى غربي المحيط
الهادي
الى تو صينيه خلال المناوره 300 طلعه انها
واحده من مناوره صينيه لم تتوقف خلال
الاشهر الماضيه واستهدفت بالخصوص تايوان
لابقائها تحت الضغط
1727 طائره صينيه ارسلت الى منطقه الدفاع
الجوي تايوان خلال 2022 مقارنه ب 380 قبل
سنتين واكثر من 100 قاذفه قنابل توغلت في
هذه المنطقه
ولاول مره تستخدم الصين المسيرات وترسل
احدى وسبعين منها الى منطقه الدفاع الجوي
لطايوان فيبدو ان كل وسائل الضغط العسكري
تستخدم حاليا في هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]